[Aplausos]
[Música]
el peor día
de mi vida laboral
fue
el homicidio en ocasión de robo de un
chico de 18 años
fue
día de lluvia en marzo
tuve que conocer a sus padres en las
peores circunstancias
y había sido
víctima y el victimario tenía la misma
edad
pero toda una historia de consumo
cuando fue apresado
y le dimos la novedad al padre
con mucha valentía dijo
hagan lo que quieran
no me importa nada va a devolver a mi
hijo
eso me llevó a mendes destruir toda mi
estructura de pensamiento a pensar no
hay una forma mejor
que castigar las conductas no deberíamos
buscar un sistema que prevenga
los delitos porque castigarlos
es tarde cuando logramos castigar un
delito este ya ocurrió y el perjuicio de
la víctima es irremediable como ese
chico de 18 años
dedique toda mi vida laboral al poder
judicial en distintos ámbitos
y estoy seguro que la gestión de los
conflictos
podría ser mucho mejor deberíamos poner
el foco en la prevención y no en el
castigo
la prevención es lo importante y el
castigo es urgente
es tremendamente frustrante que todos
los días uno resuelve un caso y aparece
uno nuevo
otro victimario otra víctima nunca
termina a veces uno se pregunta cuándo
terminan las personas que cometen
delitos de dónde salen y eso es lo que
me ha llevado a reflexionar
cuál es la forma de evitar que surjan
nuevas personas que cometen delitos y lo
que tenemos que hacer es sumergirnos en
las circunstancias que cada persona tuvo
para transformarse en un delincuente
para poder trabajar desde ámbitos
distintos al sistema penal y prevenir
que es a ese proceso de degradación se
lleve adelante
tuve el caso de enrique un chico de 23
años
había estado preso desde los 18 hasta
los 23 por robo y a los 15 días de salir
en libertad fue detenido
pronto al robarle un local en belgrano
durante los cinco años que enrique
estuvo preso
no pudo aprender a leer y escribir
tampoco pudo antes
pero él se jactaba orgulloso de saber
firmar con su nombre
en cinco años que el establo de tubo no
le enseña leer y escribir
no aprendió un oficio no pudo trabajar
ni tener un trabajo el día que salía
cuánto tiempo podría durar en libertad
qué culpa tuvo enrique realmente de
volver a reincidir en ese delito cuando
cinco años lo privamos la libertad para
que simplemente el tiempo transcurra un
castigo list villano sin aportarle nada
a esa vida para poder darle una nueva
oportunidad un renacer
cuando digo mi presente
que puede ser el de algunos otros
entiendo que me he podido desarrollar me
puede terminar el colegio estudia la
universidad forme una familia tengo una
carrera
pero s
éxito de mi presente no es mérito
exclusivo mío
responde a una sucesión
de esfuerzos mancomunados de todas las
personas que me precedieron en la vida
yo no tengo ningún mérito en especial
fue el resultado de mis padres y mis
padres fue resultado de mis abuelos y
mis hijos serán el resultado de mi
esfuerzo para que ellos logren forjar un
futuro
cuándo
yo era chico
no me gustaba ir a la escuela esas
mañanas de invierno envidiaba a mi perro
que se quedaba burlón de vuelta una
frazada mientras yo medida con el
delantal congelado y mi mamá me llevaba
a la escuela
yo no decidí a ir a la escuela yo
hubiese preferido quedarme en mi casa y
ese esfuerzo de mi madre fue lo que
logró que yo me transforme a una persona
de bien
y ese esfuerzo de mi madre ella lo hacía
porque tuvo una situación parecida
cuando era chica y entendía el valor de
la educación
cuando tenía seis años mis padres de
separados
al principio fue muy shockeante pero
después empecé a descubrir ciertos
beneficios
eran dos adultos peleando por mi amor
eran dobles vacaciones dos regalos de
cumpleaños y una situación de
alternancia entre uno y otro que era muy
cómodo pero a veces esa comodidad se
terminaba
generalmente después de un boletín con
algunas notas bajas y vi villa un
llamado de mi madre a mi padre que decía
gerardo tenemos que hablar
ahí me corrió un hilo por la espalda
de terror y frío y entonces iban a un
bar tomaban un café hablaban del
susodicho y me citaban con la única
ventaja de tomar una coca cola que era
un bien escaso en aquellos tiempos y
después vine a esa amenaza esa bajeza
si no mejoras las notas te vamos a poner
un colegio cupido
yo no sabía bien que ir a un colegio
pupilo pero me imaginaba que nada bueno
de panamá en mi futuro
así que trataba de ahondar el esfuerzo
para poder salir adelante eso
es lo que a mí me llevo al futuro y lo
entendés el día que como padre te
encontrás diciendo barbaridades
similares a tus hijos
pero esta no es la realidad de todos
ha sido mi ventaja
pero qué pasa cuando eso no se da en el
seno de una familia que pasa cuando
nadie lo despierta un chico paraguayas
del colegio qué pasa cuando no tiene
para comer
y no se puede levantar la mañana
qué pasa cuando se fuma un porro en la
esquina del colegio
qué pasa cuando deja de ir al colegio
qué pasa cuando sufre maltrato
qué pasa cuando reparte estampitas en el
subte
qué pasa cuando sufre abusos
no pasa nada
cuando vemos un chico fumando pasta base
o aspirando poxirrán
no pasa nada
porque el estado no aborda estos
conflictos no está preparado
para abordar esos conflictos no tiene
herramientas las docentes muchas veces
no tienen que hacer la educación en las
que tienes obligatoria pero eso es un
enunciado no es real no pasa nada si un
chico deja de ir a la escuela y la
escuela tiene que ser un foco de
intervención estatal en cada uno de
estos niños y hoy no lo es
y entonces
a eso le sumamos chicos cuyas madres en
muchos casos están solas pasan largas
jornadas de trabajo los chicos quedan a
merced de barrios vulnerables donde hay
personas de malvivir que los combinan
con estupefacientes
los someten a las adicciones 12 13 14
años empiezan a cometer delitos
son impunes a los delitos pues son
chiquitos entonces el el sistema penal
no actúa porque soy un imputarles y
nadie más se hace responsable no hay
otro organismo del estado que aborde un
chico de 13 años que entró a robar
aparece una noticia tras robar y todos
piden baja en la edad de inimputabilidad
como si fuese una respuesta mágica
mandemos a la cárcel ahora qué pasa que
este chico está robando tiene 13 años
no puede ser no es normal que pase eso y
no es normal que el estado no tenga
herramientas para abordarlo
entonces
y empieza una espiral
de decadencia de la persona
empieza a caer preso empieza a tener
adicciones no tenemos herramientas para
abordar los problemas de adicción no
tenemos cupos de internación
yo he tenido chicos de 13 14 y 15 años
detenidos y que no sabían las fechas de
su cumpleaños
no se acordaban cuando habían nacido y
une siempre como no te acordás
cuántos años tienes cuando naciste y si
el pegamento me borró la cabeza
y cuando uno lograba dar con las madres
o con los padres o con las abuelas
desean dejarlo preso no lo quiero ir a
buscar porque no lo puedo manejar
y me está arruinando al resto de los
chicos
y finalmente los jueces lo dejaban ir
sin ninguna respuesta gubernamental y
esa respuesta va a llegar
pero va a llegar cuando es más grande o
cuando cometa delitos más graves
ese día así llega la respuesta y la
respuesta llega de la peor manera porque
la única herramienta que el estado
encuentra es a través de la sanción
penal
entonces ese chico que tuvo un montón de
derechos vulnerados durante un montón de
años después es castigado severamente
porque no se adecua a las normas
todas esas normas que no le garantizaron
sus derechos en su infancia y en su
inglés son las que después se la aplican
en su contra
y siempre se aplica
de la peor manera a través del sistema
punitivo ista y de la prisión es el
lugar donde van a ser depositados como
fue enrique donde no van a aprender nada
donde van a sufrir mayor cantidad de
delitos que los que ellos cometieron
para estar ahí
la cárcel el lugar donde se destruye a
las personas
todo lo que vaya a ir va a salir peor
hay un viejo
dicho del derecho penal que dice que el
derecho penal es la última ratio es la
última opción que utiliza el estado para
resolver un conflicto
en los últimos años esa última ratio se
transformó en la única ratio es la única
el único espacio gubernamental donde se
le da el poder al estado para corregir
todas las conductas sociales y
lamentablemente el sistema penal tiene
una sola herramienta en su caja de
herramientas que es un martillo para
producir daño a las personas es la
función que nosotros tenemos en la
sociedad castigar a los que se portan
mal
y yo no quiero decir con esto que esté
mal aplicar sanciones por supuesto que
no cada uno tiene que hacerse
responsable de las conductas disvaliosas
con las cuales afectan los derechos de
otros
eso está perfecto pero si volvemos a la
pronuncia la pregunta inicial de esta
charla sí que preferimos nosotros si
sufrió un daño y que la persona que nos
produjo ese daño se ha condenado a un
peor de los infiernos o que por el
contrario nunca nos pase nada siempre
vamos a preferir que no pase nada
entonces el camino debe ser otro
y la energía debe estar puesta en
prevenir las conductas y no en sancionar
las
sancionar las conductas que nos han
perjudicado es lo urgente pero lo
importante es prevenirlas y la
prevención es evitando que haya chicos
que caigan en este espiral descendiente
hacia el delito
en el ejemplo de eeuu y canadá es muy
interesante en este aspecto
eeuu tiene la tasa de prisión por cada
100.000 habitantes más grande del mundo
tiene seiscientos cincuenta y cinco
presos por cada 100.000 habitantes
canadá que también responde a un sistema
anglosajón
pero tiene una vida puesta más en la
integración en la prevención
que se ocupa mucho más de la niñez y de
la juventud tiene 150 detenidos por cada
100.000 habitantes
eeuu tiene cuatro veces más tasa de
homicidios
supera incluso a nuestro país tenemos
mejores tasas de homicidios por cada mil
habitantes que eeuu y tenemos la mitad
de detenidos que ellos
si como sociedad buscamos proteger la
niñez proteger la infancia y utilizamos
la educación pública como un basamento
de la igualdad de oportunidades en 20
años nadie tendría que tener el delito
como una opción muchas gracias
[Aplausos]